hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we left off
I died stupid stupid stupid stupid
anyway laughing alright I've got plenty
of ammo actually for once I've got lots
and lots of animals how much do I have
in storage I haven't checked in a while
I've got a good bit in storage if I ever
want to change out to like the rivet gun
or something either good opportunity to
do that even the bolts rifle and one med
kit I mean I'm in pretty good shape I
don't need to do anything for once
actually I need a bit of help but
whatever helps a station give it give it
give it
- okay ah there we go
ah
oh you still ugly babies burn oh no I
let go of the pulse rifle damn it I can
just throw stuff at you you slob right
find anything to thrive yeah die give me
that fine fine brush okay don't use the
detonator on the big fat ladies are they
lady there guy I don't know maybe this
is where it was fashioned kid that's
where oh hello that definitely wasn't a
power node there for maybe there was and
then mister I have been known to miss
things where is it I hear it I hear it I
do not see it oh there it is let's not
bother leave it up oh come on ma'am I
got just so few things - OH
[Music]
give me something
I don't wanna murder these things these
are annoying ah hell are you fasting
haha not fast enough
I forgot dead bodies kill shut up guys
no I hear it I swear I hear it oh right
there never mind
couldn't do anything to be anyway what
the hell come on man take that and take
that there are you now I need to have a
med kit thank you are you happy now
I can I finally progress I hear so many
of these goopy things there you go
you're dead
congratulations all I'm going into the
elementary school I'm creeped out
already
those smiley balloon sons aren't doing
any justice
I know oh oh oh oh god why oh well uh Oh
God
I know is I'm not acting oh I hate it
hate it hate it all when things blow up
like that
Oh Oh gives me the willies oh one one it
creeps me out more than anything that
fear the trip to phobia for your holes
it's more than that
Oh God I just I can't all I can't look
at it oh they don't have to get like the
movie Cloverfield the movie itself was
bad but I'm not gonna spoil anything but
for the middle part you know what I'm
talking about you know you just saw that
you know what I'm talking about that
creeped me out to no end I couldn't
stand that I had haunted my dreams
[Music]
oh don't play nice friends are sleeping
oh no oh no
[Music]
why aren't you blowing up huh ah it's
not that I mind things blowing up like
those enemies although baby's blowing up
was pretty creepy and pretty sick ah
pretty sadistic but one thing's blow up
in like bodies swell up and explode or
they blow up in a minute
I just they blow up from the inside it's
just I only want to talk about it I hear
more good like these babies are a favor
ah babies are not okay not what I'm
saying but I mean you know don't make me
talk about it
Oh
oh just go away
[Music]
dong ding dong ding ding dong thank you
the darker one Mele where I hit things
it seems to be a timeout chair uh looks
like you got timeout oh yeah I couldn't
I couldn't think of a joke I'm lame like
that another like took time out of your
life yeah wash your hands
those that mr. moon I don't like this
place I don't like it at all
[Music]
not one bit Rochester hex log well I
haven't read anything in a while
the kids are the kids are playing way
too rough on the playground yesterday I
literally had a line of students with
scrapes and bruises going out my office
door a few kids sustained injuries bad
enough to need to go the infirmary call
me old-fashioned but I think this is the
problem with the kids with kids growing
up on a space station kids need a planet
with fresh air and open ground to plan
otherwise they go stir-crazy and start
picking on each other space is no place
to raise a family if you ask me
well considering that's probably you and
you're dead
shows what you know uh-huh yeah nurses
I've had my fill of nurses in horror
games nightmare house two man
Chapter six has been going on quite a
while time to say like the first five
chapters I just flew through but these
No
sighs are going crazy again totally
called that scare though
totally totes man ah stuff people things
ah I know you get killed by just a
little Oh
whoop-whoop we've killed you I didn't
kill you ah walk uh I got you
you said drop me lots of good I like
these little kid monsters
[Music]
wah-wah huh
ah I knew it something I knew something
happened
they try some else on you don't spit at
me
dammit damn and I'm all slow I didn't
know their spit did that
I'm really slow it'd be bad because that
guy
okay med pack it's ready but not yet I
only have medium ones oh no I asked
Molly okay good
okay what do we got here line gun I got
plenty of I got em oh oh
send that stupid son get over yourself
what is this what is this okay hello
come in oh he'll awesome hacking skills
[Music]
hubris as they would call it there we go
all about it that do why did I need to
do that I mean seriously what was the
point of that
oh why was that necessary oh oh oh I
knew it I knew it
give me your head or get here I need to
use you to do this need it yeah kiss
head boom
banging Bob guy here
stomp where your bodies go away
Thank You cactus plant aah aah oh no I
need that hotel bar
we got that there we go
I just got to be good about hitting them
and making sure they drop their items
before words their body because there's
only like the more there are the more
bodies go away so I'd like to keep them
in the game so I could explain all their
items
really
he's it really mother [ __ ] do i yeah
yeah yeah mother I never know is that
before that's really cool
it's a nice little touch I mean I don't
know what practical application has but
that's really cool
gives them some character review if I
get really pissed off at something I
could be like you
that's actually pretty satisfying all
the blood squirting everywhere guy I'd
make a good Isaac's voice wouldn't wait
this is just the way I came why did I
come in there
[Music]
hex logging teacher or third semester I
know the kids are supposed to have a
vivid imagination but this is getting
ridiculous
nearly half of my class has imaginary
friends now claiming that it's their
deceased grandmother or something
normally this wouldn't be a problem but
it's getting harder and harder to get
these kids to concentrate this semester
I've sent more students to the timeout
chair than I have in all my 12 years of
teaching maybe these kids are having
trouble at home I've also noticed
parental involvement steadily decreasing
this semester
Walter Blake yep it's craziness I know
this flavor and maybe I should give the
flame to another tribe probably it is
much better with crowds of little kids
like that javelin just isn't cutting it
what's the alt fire nothing whoa okaasan
Hamilton damn okay maybe I misunderstood
it
oh wait a minute I'm not oh this isn't
the same place okay I thought it was all
peridot can't get away from me ah yep
sure am I'm smart what I try to shoot
you ha come on for you yeah whatever
you're not scary not that scary sharing
it all Isaac just cuz you're crazy
doesn't mean I'm crazy does it
Oh actually that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you guys actually
nah I need to go I need to go forward
and find a safe point either price a
point like right around whoa hello yeah
Billy go uh-huh he looks twitchy I don't
trust him either but then again I don't
trust you baby
how pretty you are but if he does
anything stupid anything I will shoot
him don't mess with Billy just cuz I
killed the last five Billy's I've had
why doesn't anyone else get a super
space suit they're naked out there those
things have big blades kilee death kill
blades Isaac's the only one smart enough
to get a suit whatever
my problem and I would like to reiterate
people have been commenting this is not
the best suit I looked it up there other
suits much better than this because this
one only has 15% armor and oh here we go
save station new it called it Punk
alright that's all the time I got for
this one sir thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye